hey what's up everyone happy friday
matthew encina here on the future
academy live stream
so excited to be here with you all were
you all tuning in let us know
in the chat down below but i'm very
excited for this episode we have
a very special guest peter pack who's
going to introduce himself in a moment
and we're going to be sharing the
process of main title
design from the beginning to end from
concept to delivery
and it's rare that we get to see this
nice inside look
into the process get to see the ideation
and then all the
the development and design work that
goes into something so big like
designing
a title for a show so i'm very excited
for today's
show so now i'm going to turn it over
to peter who's going to introduce
himself and let us know what he does
welcome to the show peter hello hello hi
hi my name is peter pack and i'm a
motion graphics
designer and art director here in la and
i designed and animated the title
sequence for godfather of harlem
which received a main title me respond
recently so that was pretty exciting and
yeah and today i'm gonna i'm glad to be
here um with you guys and i'm gonna talk
a little bit about
just how this project was developed and
how i came up
how i came to that collage design and
how
it was implemented for this project yes
fantastic fantastic so just so
everyone is uh familiar with what we're
talking about
jonah if you could uh play the clip the
title sequence from the show so
we know what we're all talking about
here
okay so this is the title sequence for
uh godfather of harlem can you tell us
more about it peter
um yeah this is this was this is
a tv show on epics that stars forest
whitaker
and it start and the story is about uh
gangster in 1960s a real life true hero
i'm not hero gangster um
real life figure that was in alcatraz
for about 11 years and then went he used
to be the
the he controlled harlem but then he
came back after 11 years
um everything has changed it's the 60s
the civil rights is happening um
heroin has entered the community there's
a lot of strife
and it's a story about him trying to
trying to find himself in that world
and um especially in this like
tumultuous time that i feel
has a lot of parallels with what's going
on today
so yeah people are saying badass
transitions that stuff looks pretty cool
and
this stuff definitely has a place in my
heart because it i love this aesthetic
yeah um we can't we
the team at digital kitchen um got
together and
came up with a lot of different ideas um
we pitched a lot of different concepts
and i was personally drawn to this
concept because it was something that
happens in the past
it was when i looked up so much
reference material
during my research where we'll show you
in a bit
a lot of it is photography footage it's
very archival
vintage the images have
scratches and dust and texture and it
shows the age of time
and that was one of the aesthetic
that really influenced me to kind of go
more towards this
uh 2d flat um
design element versus maybe more some of
the more like flashier
like 3d
yeah definitely i think it's very
appropriate for a historical piece like
this
uh yeah so definitely uh
loving that kind of stuff i just want to
give a shout out to everybody who's
joining us
live people from canada guatemala
colombia
everybody's saying what's up oh people
know that guy think you got some fans in
here peter some homies
but yeah people people are looking at
this and they're pretty amazed because
when you look at something
that's finished like this when you're
watching this on tv
you don't really know how it's made or
how much work it takes and
if you are doing things like graphic
design or motion design
you might look at that and see this
massive gap between your skills
and something like that where it's it's
just it's gorgeous at the end of the day
so i'm hoping that you can uh peel back
some of the layers and
and share us how we got to that how do
we how do we get to something like that
there yeah for sure for sure um
should i should we start the
presentation i'd like to just start
while
text is on the screen so that yeah i'm
not just reading it you know
yeah people can just look at it they
could tune me out and just read
the writing now let's jump in
yeah let's see are we there yet oh yeah
sweet
so yeah um godfather of harlem meantime
development
let's see let me see if my keyboard
is working sweet all right
um i mean we're talking about main title
development
um usually it starts with a creative
brief uh digital kitchen chris brancato
who was the showrunner and creator of
narcos
who we had previously worked with came
back to us and
narcos was you know such a mind-blowing
um
main title too when it first came out
and he wanted something
that would be similarly ambitious
something that would have a lot of
detail and scope
and especially nowadays with with main
titles
starting to become a little bit shorter
because of the you know the
people's attention spans the skip intro
button
um he thought that going doing
a a one minute thirty main title
would you know it's it's definitely
gonna be ambitious so i mean
he came at us with the creative brief
how god
and um godfather of harlem is an
examination of a world with deep
contemporary parallels there's a lot of
things going on back then
that are that we could kind of see going
on and today
um culturally politically there's still
the problems of back then like police
brutality heroin addiction
a divided nation um crime
um we're kind of viewing and confronting
a lot of those issues
through the prism of the 1960s and
let's see so when we when we when chris
when the showrunner the show people the
client first comes at us
with an idea of like okay this is what
we want
you know what is it gonna you know like
what's it gonna look like is it gonna be
hand puppets is it gonna be flashy 3d is
it going to be
lego stop-motion we all have to not you
know
those are just some wild ideas but then
we have to
um start asking a lot of questions
to them so that we have a better
understanding
of what the material is going to be and
what is it that they
and what is the story that they want to
tell and i listed
some five little thumbnails i mean some
five little
questions at the bottom how to position
the show how to portray
um because i'm talking about the
godfather of harlem i'll be kind of
using this as a guide uh to explore
these concepts
um how to portray the era of harlem how
to portray bumpy johnson in the civil
rights movement
how to portray the evolution of seasons
and if you notice there's a lot of
how questions you know how do we make a
main title how do we
you know develop a concept and
you asked you you talked about how do we
go from
you know how does one go from nothing
you know to ending up with something
that's really finished
and the the easy way
i mean the easy way is the easy place to
start
is to ask a lot of questions the basics
the who what where when why how trying
to keep it a lot
trying to keep things simple it i think
there's a lot of anxiety in the
beginning
when there's a lot of option paralysis
and things can get very
stressful when we try to decide and try
to make decisions
but i think when we try to focus on
these five questions first
uh five counting that they're five nope
there's the one six yes there's sure um
see i can't count
yeah um then it'll help create
a a bet a better clear way to
arrive at where where you end up going
so
using this project as a guide
for the question of who um i asked i
asked i had to ask myself
who is this show about you know
who is this show uh being told to who's
the audience
um who are the characters um
so coming up with just a lot of just
doing a lot of research
um trying to talk trying to figure out
who the characters are
um the main characters of the show while
there are many
is uh bumpy johnson who is our main
character protagonist
anti-hero who was a mobster boss but
also a family man
he was someone of extremely high
intelligence he was a poet
a chess master a family man yet he was
also a killer and a gangster
so how does a man that is able to
um be a family man take care of his
community
how is he able to rationalize um being a
gangster and also a drug dealer who
brings into
brings drugs into his communities you
know how does he rationalize that
the second character is malcolm x who
was a very famous
um civil rights activist and a muslim
minister
and he and the third character is adam
clayton powell jr who was a congressman
and the fourth character is vicente the
chin gigante who was
an italian mob boss and the show
basically explores the relationships
of these four characters some of their
the alliances that they make the
betrayals
and how they're able to sometimes uh
move forward because
in essence this show
in addressing the what is about the
american dream
it's about crime it's about family it's
about violence
politics religion existential choice
things aren't really black and white
there every
time we make choices it sometimes
we have to make compromises you know who
do we like
even though we might have a lot of
people or things that we want to do or
protect you know
some of the times the choices are made
for us
um so a lot of these um
images that i'm showing up on screen are
kind of
from my initial research and my mood
boards
um one of the things you want to do in
the beginning to kind of try to get a
good sense of what the ideas and visuals
can be
is to come up with a mood board a mood
board is just a collection
of images that kind of
re like relate to or something draws to
you it could be the color it could be
the content of the images
just something that you feel like can
better help you
focus on what you want and
let's see for the question of where
um this plate this takes place in harlem
new york
it was a predominantly black
neighborhood it had it was famous for
its nightclubs
it's um it's a music scene
but it was and it was actually very
diverse at the time too
a lot of puerto ricans italians and
black people lived together
in harlem and within the island of
manhattan and
some of the imagery i did research um
trying to see
what was the photography what was the
aesthetic what was
the fashion um even the colors of the
time
that is being portrayed um when when
was when was a very important question
to ask
because this is a historical um
drama and it takes place in the 1960s it
was when the space race was happening
cassius clay was still going as cassius
clay
there was the vietnam war happening
kennedy was president
and segregation was very rampant this
was
a little bit before the civil rights act
was signed
so that a lot of the marching and the
protests were still happening
um why uh the question
of why is why could be like why is this
story being told
why is this being told now um
and the answer that i came up is that it
is
culturally relevant and shows kind of
the parallels
to the present there's a mark twain
quote that says
history doesn't repeat itself but it
often rhymes
i'm a fan of history and storytelling
and i i love the fact that
we could look to the past to kind of
guide us towards
how we should are able to identify
ourselves and how
we can look and act towards the future
and
i purposely um oriented the images that
you see on the screen here to kind of be
mere reflections of itself
so that it shows that a lot of the
things that happened in the past are
still going on today
and whether it's equal rights income
inequality
racism or drugs to name a few the show
reveals how similar and relevant these
issues remain to this day it reminds us
that the fight for the american dream is
an ongoing struggle
and each new generation has an
obligation to bring forward positive
change
yeah that's that's wonderful and people
are complimenting you so far peter on
your presentation
very great ideas i'm just staring into
space
no this is good yeah i wanted to give
you some feedback as people are saying
like these are
you know really nice articulate thoughts
and then also being able to see
the types of questions that you ask and
where it leads you to
especially into uh you know where we're
going to arrive to for the final output
of the the design that you make so
i just wanted to compliment you on that
and give you some love there thank you
thank you very much and uh be sure to
tell me if i'm leaning too forward
and you're getting too much of you too
much forehead
now we're good man all right i got that
covet hair going on yeah that's right
all right um so oh yeah and then the
last question
how how is the most difficult question
to answer
um we have to you know go through all
the who what where when why
in order to really be able to answer the
how and
the mood these images are the images
that kind of
appealed to me in terms of some of the
aesthetic the grunge the texture
the typography the colors um
and what i realized appealed to me was
the archival
vintage photographic and really tactile
aspects of this time period um
and that's kind of how and during my
research if you look at
what is it the far right image center
there was this image that is
in this page it's the top left i found
this image it was
the cover of a root of a roots album
and
i did a lot and then i got something
about it really appealed to me and then
i did
more research into where it came from
and who did it and surprisingly i was
just
it just went me down a rabbit hole of
just
learning and being inspired um
and i think in turn when i want to talk
about
inspiration i want to talk a little bit
about inspiration
um how i mean and this is my personal
attitudes
regarding you know just how i think and
how i design
but i feel like in order to be able to
be inspired sometimes we have you know
like a writer's block in our head we
don't know what to do
we scrolled pinterest for hours and
coming up with nothing
to be inspired we have to of course
first have a large range
of interests to draw inspiration from
you know try try to um
be a person of the world try to you know
even if it's just going online
even if it's just subscribing to
different
stuff that is outside of what you
have interest in that's definitely
helpful but i think one of the most
important aspects
is to have empathy and what i mean by
empathy is being able to see
through the eyes of someone else it
doesn't mean that you have to agree with
them
it just means that you could kind of put
yourself in their shoes for a little
moment and be like
okay i could kind of see that's where
it's coming from or that's how
they think or was made and when you look
so that when you look at different
things try
look at different perspectives you kind
of try to put yourself in their shoes
and see what were the choices that
why what what and why were the choices
that they made
and what are the issues that
they care about and why they're they
have they have
and how they have put that into their
heart i think
um what is it
there is an issue where i could look at
something
think it's great and appropriate it for
something else that is completely uh
not relevant towards the original um
creator
and that's basically cultural
appropriation where you steal
art and you do it in a way that doesn't
respect
the original creators doesn't respect
credit or benefit
the original creators and further
contributes to their marginalization
especially if we're talking about a
black guard or
art made by marginalized
demographics and i tried to
do it in a way that was very
respectful i did it i
tried to do it in a way that would be
more of a tribute and pay homage
to the original artist who was romer
bearden
who created all these artworks and and
tried to do it in a way where i hoped
not to elevate myself
in the creation of this main title but
to kind of give tribute to the fighters
and activists in the past
who fought for the american dream so
that when people see this main title
they're not thinking about me they're
thinking about
the subject matter the issues that this
show
that this main title and the show sparks
and
and also bring light and awareness to
romero bearden and other
black artists um yeah so that was my
little rant
about no i think it's important i think
it's important that um
when you look at stuff um that you don't
just take
and just photo bash everything together
and steal steel steel without
you know properly understanding and i'm
very guilty of this i've done this
all of my career and you know it
it takes some time before you can
actually look back in some maturity
once you've had your own art stolen your
own thing stolen and you look back
you're like oh that didn't feel good
and then you start to realize you know
the people that are out there the
other hard-working artists and then all
of a sudden it's like
yeah you should pay homage you should
pay respect and
if you are appropriating something make
sure you do it appropriately and make
sure that it's
um uh that it's it's appropriate for the
application right because
you wouldn't just use this for just
anything right you found this very
particular thing and it kind of weave
together
all of the other research and questions
you've asked up until this point so
i think that was a great little rant for
you to share with us in the audience
yeah um and ever since uh this main
title came out i've had people reach out
to me going like
oh my gosh this collage style that you
know
you designed is great um i would like
you know
can you make you know use that style for
this
you know sport high school sports
documentary that
i'm trying to produce and when when
people come to me with those kind of
questions
it makes me uncomfortable because i
developed this style as
an as paying homage to romero bearden
to uh black artists and the
issues that were um being that that were
relevant to this artwork
and i wouldn't feel comfortable
um redoing romero's particular
style of collage for some other
application you know and i think that's
kind of the difference
between uh cultural appropriation
and possible and appreciation um you
know we could
even though the black community created
hip-hop hip-hop is worldwide and but
that doesn't mean that
um if you know a japanese person loves
hip-hop that that's appropriation i
think
the level of respect the level of credit
um whether it uplifts or celebrates and
appreciates the marginalized community
is definitely important to how
um you know these things should be
framed
um yeah and i'll talk so i'll talk a
little bit about romero beard and what i
found
um he was a black artist back then he
actually
lived in harlem in the 60s exactly
the same setting and time period that
this show takes place in
and he's most known for his photo
montage
uh compositions that used uh torn
magazines
um different uh photographs and textures
to
assemble um powerful statements on
african american life and
let's see we felt um his art was
relevant to the show because it shared
themes and portrayals of social
inequality
and the african-american experience that
the show similarly explores
and the tactile and tangible textures of
the collage
as well as its ability to present and
juxtapose
different subjects from different
sources within a single composition
was very highly influential to this main
idea
so i mean this is more of the
continuation um so i talk about research
you know
luck you know purely by coincidence
there was an exhibition called soul of a
nation
uh art in the age of black power
1963-1983
our show takes place in 1963 and it was
touring
and in los angeles at the time um
at the broad museum road broad broad
brook and brody
no one knew in the beginning and whoever
said they knew was
lying anyways and then um so
i was actually able to see that exact
artwork up close the second panel is me
next to it and you know i thought it'd
be something big
and i was so surprised that it was
something so small but then
the amount of you know detail that you
could see the amount
of textures the amount of layering i
mean
so all the images from the previous
uh frame the previous frame the
previous slide were actually all um
images that i took myself with my phone
you know
you could kind of trying to do that
research what does a paper edge
look like when it's torn you know sure i
could
do it at home but if i'm trying to
pay homage to this artist i want to try
to make it
at least a little bit closer towards
what how he has
done and his compositions i read the
autobot
biography of malcolm x which is one of
the best books i have ever read i highly
recommend this to everyone
um bumpy johnson his
wife wrote a biography on bumpy johnson
and i read that too and i think it's
very important
when you're trying to immerse yourself
into a concept
to really try to you know do the proper
amount of research
and you know just find out everything
you know about it you know just
just become passionate um let's say
next slide and here's an example of some
of the ways
that here's one just particular
example of um how some of his
imagery influenced other than the
aesthetic
um on the left slide is romer bearden's
rocket to the moon
and it's a collage that depicts people
living in the slums
and at first it looks like when you look
at it at first glance
um the faces are the things that your
eyes kind of get drawn towards
and it looks like happy faces and people
are having fun but then you see
like start seeing the grim worried faces
of the other people in the
collage you start you see downcast eyes
um
eyes that look like they've been crying
mouth that looked like they've been
screaming or crying and at the top
almost like it should not be there
in the red circle is a rocket ship and
you know what the heck is this rocket
ship be in this work
and it's a representation of how the
country
in the past and present spends all its
efforts into advances in technology and
warfare
all the while leaving the problems of
the people that society
that the people of society faces behind
and it's such a simple yet powerful
uh message and the way he was it
used um the different uh
the different photographs the different
materials from composition
to kind of tell this message i think was
really powerful and with some of the
ways that it made
and i paid homage homage to it
um at the bottom two frames the center
one
was my first pitch frame and
the one on the right is the final
screenshot i it moved over to that
different
uh scene but that's kind of one of the
ways that it came into
the main title and
you know this was this is such a
powerful statement because
during the 1960s you know of all all the
social
social strife um civil rights happening
yet what was america and the government
focused on the civil
i mean not civil war the civil um the
cold war
civil war the cold war uh
the race to the moon right yeah the race
the race to the moon you know
yeah yeah and that's just some of the
ways
how he talked about um societal issues
that people
uh faced at the time and i thought that
that was
particularly relevant um for this
concept
and so this this is the pitch this is
the you know pretty much exactly how we
pitched it i mean
we put in a deck where we also included
a bunch of
different great concepts um but this is
pretty much
exactly how i showed it and this is the
little write-up that i came up with
and i talked about how we were inspired
by romero bearden how it was relevant
because he lived during this time period
and talked about the same issue that the
show similarly explores
and there will there was a quote also by
rachel duluth who is an uh us
who is an art history professor she said
the cutting fragmenting and
reconstruction
involved and creating a collage provides
act
metaphors for the trauma and violence of
war
and political oppression the
evisceration of the status quo
and the piecing together of new societal
forms
and that was the quote that really
nailed
this whole collage uh
concept into my head that this is the
one you know
because what i really loved about
collage
is that if i were to take a picture of
you
and people were to look at that picture
they wouldn't they would just think oh
that's him
you know but if i were to
make a collage of not just your face
but many different faces then it is no
longer a picture that represents you
it is a picture that represents um
people
like you as a whole so when i see when
we create collage where people's faces
are created from different materials
we're not talking about one particular
person we're not talking about one
particular black man it's representative
of all black men or all black people and
i think that was
one of the ways that collage definitely
does what does well and great at
let's see so in the beginning um when we
do a pitch
uh i don't know i mean i we do
about nine frames nine frames is i think
perfect for
um just getting your idea across i think
three frames in the beginning three
frames for the beginning
uh middle you know ending i think nine
frames is enough to tell a story
and these are the frames that i kind of
came up with um and when i came up with
this
i wanted the the thought process in my
head
was what is the story that we're trying
to tell
what are the who's you know
what is the story who is the story about
all the questions that
were answered earlier and let's see
the frame one top left i wanted to
establish the setting
you know it happens kind of in the city
in the urban area
um the signage kind of shows uh
the signage kind of shows like the city
um what what
um were important at the time or just
you know just
getting the a feel for the environment
the second one the second frame
kind of represented a society kind of
being toward
torn the society's values being torn um
between
piety and um
hedonism maybe about people that
were wanted like how drugs
and were kind of entering the community
breaking families and people apart
um the third frame was a frame where i
wanted to include
footage just to get it to get an idea to
the client of course that this wouldn't
be all collage
we're also going to include archival
footage
so having a frame that includes
something like that
can definitely help the client
understand um
let's see so some of the more signage
some
um to see or is it get an idea of
the setting the middle frame frame five
talks you know um gives a little clue
like little
talks a little bit about um just the
violence
uh in the community um kind of hints at
the
italian mob association uh associations
with this uh in this story number six is
about
um box uh what is it a boxer fighting
uh community and i particularly like
this frame
just because um
[Music]
you know it's it parallels a lot of
what's going on right now too how
uh especially with colin kaepernick
people say like oh you're an athlete you
shouldn't
be talking about politics you know you
should just play but here we have a
boxer
who is outside the ring getting attacked
by a police dog and it represents him
fighting
society because at the time and
currently today
society is afraid of black men um
they're afraid of their anger
and at the time and especially in the
60s
one of the outlets
of black men's aggression that was
societal
that society approved of was
in sports you know um
and boxing where a man could unleash his
aggression
and still be what is it
that was accepted by society but if he
were to use his position
his platform his fame his voice
to voice the concerns that he has
his opinions or his the issues that are
important to him
then society tries to uh you know
silence him and i think that's kind of
what that frame is talking about
um number seven talked about
was it just uh civil rights and
um crime protesting surveillance just a
little bit broad you know
it's hard to kind of try to capture
everything into nine frames so it's
try to get a little bit of everything
number eight is about kind of the
protests and the civil rights
that were really relevant at the time
includes the little rocket ship on top
and then at the end you know the frame
uh the logo
godfather of harlem and even if these
nine frames
are very you know like you it's very
hard to tell
a lot the whole story with just nine
frames but if you could condense
your ideas into these um style frames
into like a design board then i think
it'll help very
get a better idea of knowing what your
concept is
and being able to better explain to the
client or
others what your concept is and the
client sees
a bunch of other similar um
was it board boards like this and that's
that was included in this presentation
so sometimes just to look
just a couple of seconds is enough for
them to know to gauge
what their initial reactions are you
know
so so can we pause there because i just
i want to spend a little bit of time on
this because this is
this is beautiful it's great to see this
and um uh
what we're looking at is just a bunch of
style frames that you had composed
inside
of a pitch and a pitch sometimes you'll
present one idea sometimes you'll
present multiple ideas like you're
talking about
but this was the idea that one and
what i like about this is i could see
just from sharing all of your previous
inspirations all the questions and
research you've done
how that's manifested in its way here
when we're looking at the typefaces when
we're looking at the imagery when we're
looking at the details of the
collage and how you're using smartthings
like the paper being torn in half
representing the community being torn by
drugs and violence
and then people figures like muhammad
ali who at the time was cassius clay and
then he became an activist and changed
his name to muhammad ali
so that how that manifested into the
boxer fighting
the police and attack dogs on the street
like all of this stuff i think is
fantastic
uh to be able to unpack and then show in
a very condensed way
and when you're pitching to clients um
for me like
my approach is like work smarter not
harder so if you could
tell the entire story with one style
frame with one image and you could sell
the idea like that's fantastic
but sometimes it takes a couple of
things like this especially if there's
an
evolution of the story of like here's
the setting here's what's going on and
then here's how
things kind of um evolve in the story
here and then
here's how they all here's what it all
means so sometimes you do need multiple
frames in order to tell that sequence so
that
when you're explaining it to the person
they can just get it they can look at
this and like oh i
i get it and i can see that and it's
very thoughtful and a lot of people are
complimenting you in the
in the comments here about your
thoughtfulness so
i just wanted to share that and and
share my thoughts on that yeah
for sure i mean it really depends on how
the client
wants how much and the client wants to
be involved in the process
um there is there is a step before this
pitch
which would be presented more like what
i showed earlier with the mood boards
uh and and the one frame you know just
to get the idea across
that way um the client you're not
spending too much time
on a concept only for it to
be rejected right away you know so that
is definitely
a viable way to present if if anything a
very efficient way to
to present um but yeah um i like
the sorry let me fix this one thing
but yeah doing i think
one like whatever amount of frame
is able to get your idea across is
the best you know try just keep it
simple some people think that they need
like 15 frames
showing the entire storyboard and
sequence or else the people aren't going
to get it
they need to include every great angle
every shot
you know um that was really cool but
that the thing about being an artist is
that you have to make decisions you have
to
uh kind of choose what is the thing that
will get
the idea across the most efficiently
effectively and in a way that's easy to
understand
um let's see so after that got approved
um you know they told me all right now
flesh it out this is
a one minute 30 second long um
title sequence you know let's let's see
what other things that we could kind of
try to include
um so this was round two of the
storyboards
uh some things remain the same some
things
changed a little bit i included uh you
see
like at the bottom frame eight you see
like an inclusion
of some of the characters um a
representation of
the italian mob uh one of the things
that the client wanted to see
is the actual um characters
not just you know abstract
representation of the time and place but
actually see visually the characters um
so that character at the bottom is the
actual
face of the actual mobster that
that the true life mobster at the time
and the little patch right there is
a patch from the actor that is
portraying him
so you know just a little way of kind of
mixing both
um the real and the fit the real
and hollywood um the past present
um let's see next frame same thing
for uh malcolm x at top left
and bumpy johnson at the bottom uh adam
clayton powell at the right and just you
know just a little bit more development
um kind of also one included a frame
that didn't make the act
the cut as a collage about the uh
the space race the astronaut kind of
going into his rocket
and shooting for the moon while leaving
society
you know behind the frame behind
the frame before that kind of showed
some of the chaos in the writing
uh rioting um that didn't make the
was it the final sequence because the
story took place
in 1963 and it was a little bit before
all the chaos and and some of the riots
happened
so we felt like that it wasn't quite the
time yet to show that
um let's see and yeah just fleshing
things out um
getting the credits you know people
really want to know how their names are
going to look like
on you know in the main title
is my name gonna be noticeable enough is
there too much you know
background like background clutterness
you know that's gonna cover it up is it
only gonna be up for like
a split second you know um people it's
it's
you would you would you would yeah
they're really that's actually very
important
so they want to see that in the in the
um
whereas in the boards and yeah
let's see so i just i just doubled the
amount of frames
um to a total of 18 to come up with
that and we also included a frame of
kind of showing what our stock footage
selects would be because these are the
examples of
the col like some of the collages but
you could see that you know we're going
to incorporate
some archival footage to better tie
in the his the the fact that it's a
historical piece
um with into the main title and you know
just showing them oh yeah these are some
of the stock
footage choices that we were thinking of
um not all made it
um the thing about stock footage
especially gettystock
is that it is very expensive
and i remember we first made
we first made an edit containing only
stock footage just to get the emotion
of the piece with kind of the music
at the time and while it did a great job
of kind of
you know maybe showing some of the
you know like emotions the
sense of timing all that it freaked the
little
people out a little bit because they're
like wait a minute how many stock
footages are we using
because you know like yeah it could
get a little bit crazy um so that's just
something also to be
aware of when you're making a main title
try to
be aware of you know how expensive it
could get try not to rely
too much on old archival footage
um and you know see you know and i and i
think those
limits actually can could also help you
think a little bit further you know push
think a little bit outside the box of
how can you get something done you know
like while
you know having a footage could have
been great you know i'll just slap it in
color treat it
you know if we're unable to do that how
can we
then get what the footage
would have emoted in a way that you know
we can that is you know
totally viable financially
there's different kinds of stock too so
for our audience who hasn't
um had to license uh stock footage or
photos before
right if it's royalty free it's
relatively inexpensive
it's it's almost free at a certain point
but when you're using
rights managed footage meaning somebody
has the rights to that
and they manage the rights based off of
your usage of it where it's going to
appear how long it's going to appear
and where it's going to appear then all
of that stuff just drives the price up
so one shot could be
ten thousand dollars one shot could be
two thousand dollars it really depends
on who owns the rights for that and how
they want to
um wheel and deal with you so yeah it
can get very very expensive
if you're using stuff that is rights
managed for something that's
gonna last three seconds you know yeah
exactly or even just a second or that's
blurred in the background so you gotta
be very careful with that
and before we move forward and maybe
you're gonna answer this already
when i look at your style frames and i
look at the proposed stock images that
you're going to use
do you guys already know how you're
going to use that
sequentially how they're going to
animate together or this is still just
like hey we're throwing stuff
out there and we'll figure it out later
um a lot of a lot of the latter um when
we
like here well here i i wanted to it has
a
semblance of some order um i wanted to
first
show the setting the time period the
environment
uh kind of go into what people are
familiar with you know harlem
it has like a nightlife it has um
you know like uh clubs but then you know
there's
underneath it all um there is
you know drugs and a split in the
community there is
crime violence there's also this
um the whole societal issues that are
happening
so when i designed this i kind of wan
did it in a way where we're kind of kind
of just coming like
going wider and wider um so that
we kind of get a sense of like
by the time that we end we got we get a
larger sense
of what was going on in that time period
you know
so i guess in that sense uh
i planned kind of the order of how i
wanted to
show this but then at the same time it's
very
adaptable to changing restructuring
reordering
adding subtracting and then
at the end definitely show um bumpy
johnson at the end
who to reveal that you know he's kind of
the main character
of this show you know um the logo at the
end so that's kind of some of the ways
that it
influences um
yes so yeah here here i basically um
everything that i was talking about how
one of the
kind of the themes that helped me
develop a frame
um what is the story that i wanted to
tell because you know when we're even
when we
like we got a concept it's locked down
now it's time to make more what's gonna
happen between this frame and that frame
what's the transition you know the
process starts over all over again you
gotta
you know get that you know get that
anxiety
you know anxiety starts all over again
but then
i think by knowing what
story you want to tell and how you want
to tell it it definitely
helps me you know would this frame of
police brutality
have worked if it was all the way in the
front you know and then
probably not you know so i think i do
like a word cloud you know of what are
the important things
um how do i want to structure it and i
literally when i created
this deck that's literally what i put
there i put the frames that
i already have but then in the blank
squares i'll just put
i'll just write down space race you know
um police brutality and i will work with
that concept
to try to come up with a composition
first um you know if there's been too
many close-ups
you know then it's time to go wide or
time to do mid
or those are some of the design elements
that kind of
influences because these frames don't
exactly
live in a vacuum they need to come
together as a whole
to tell the larger story and i think
that is why we put them
in a frame like in a
design board like this where we could
kind of see them all up
like while we do present them so that
afterwards we could see
one frame full frame um it's important
to be able to
kind of just look at it as a whole you
know even step back from your computer
and look at it
from like 20 feet away see what you know
what how how are the colors looking
how's the lighting looking
um they just all need to work together
as a whole and when you understand that
coming up with what you need to tell
that story
is a lot more simpler
so yeah and these are the final these
are the screenshots
of what the final um frames ended up
looking like
um and that's the thing in the beginning
things could be very rough like i mean
let's go back to that
first where is it yeah look at that it's
like
everything's a lot there's it's very
different from
what it ended up being but it's
like does it does does it do a job of
kind of telling what it can be
you know like clients know that um
you know whatever is going to be shown
is most likely going to be rough and
it's going to be
go through rounds of revisions and
probably get better
with production and as more eyes and
hands kind of see and touch it
but then you know does that initial
pitch that wins
the you know that will win the pitch
does it do a good job of kind of showing
what it can be because when someone sees
a pitch they don't just want they're not
looking at it
just to see uh what it
is they kind of also want to see what it
can be
and it's always open to improvement
and uh change you know
and let's see so yeah these are some of
the
the final collages how it ended up
looking and
becoming um and and
was it i mean i couldn't have done this
by myself uh my creative director
mason was that was um it was
was very important at giving me um a lot
of nails that kind of helped me
push myself to um
really push this aesthetic to try to
make it a little bit better um
making me add transitions where i really
wanted just to cut
you know i'm like i don't have time to
make the transition i just wanted to cut
right there you know but he's like nope
it needs it and i'm like
and months later months later i'm
grumbling
the whole time but months later i'm like
damn it he was right you know like
it's great you know and um
you know and that's the thing about team
members uh you don't always have to
agree with them
but you know especially if you respect
them as an artist
as a person it's something that you want
to
um you know just try to incorporate a
little bit you know
and while i did come up with um a lot of
the initial designs um
it just went through a lot of steps a
lot of eyes
um it was a geopant she
oh yeah so i had two other uh junior
animators that were working with me
um was it geo had just graduated from
otis
and i saw her at the senior show and i
saw that
she did some work that did include some
collage and
told a story about her family and
her family from vietnam and a little bit
of her family story and i thought that
was really great
and when she when she came to digital
kitchen i was like yes you know like
you know i was like finally getting some
help
you know and she was uh
she was very great at um helping me um
design designs
things here and there um helping me with
animating uh cisco torres who was
another animator
um he came and helped with a lot of the
the let's see just like little animation
elements
um creating some of the at the reveal
mats
creating a lot of the textures um
um couldn't have done it without without
those twos helps
and let's see
let's see yeah and then these are some
of the footage that
um the archival footage some of not all
of them are archival footage from
gettystock
some of them are the show production
footage so we got those for free
um some of them yeah you know i mean
every any time you get a job you gotta
ask
you know the client you know what what
do we got to work with you know like
is this show like already made is there
a pilot is there a script can we read
the script can we see the pilot
um are there any production assets maybe
you know like you might not think
it might be helpful but hey maybe i
could you know it might spur
an inspiration or maybe i could use it
for a little tiny assets anywhere
so you know definitely ask for those
things um
[Music]
let's see yeah and then uh
i wanted to talk a little bit about just
the overall collage effect you know
people when they saw this they were like
ah how did you make this
you know because uh you know i mean it's
collage
it's very tactile it's
it's you know it looks paperly and it
kind of has that like jittery
stop-motion look
i think if we had you know filmed this
practically
it would have been impossible and i
probably would have been making it
still but yeah
and then um yeah some of the so we
decided you know i decided that uh
was it it's totally viable
and efficient to create this entirely in
after effects and photoshop
while some paper elements were shot
practically in a live action shoot
to kind of um get some textures or help
with
some transitions or pieces here and
there um
majority like 95 of it was all just
after effects in photoshop um
and and very simple really i mean
to it's a lot simpler i mean you know
as a whole is very complex but to create
this effect
was actually really simple and i think
uh one thing i also want to talk about
is how
like i've talked about the schedule the
production schedule for this
uh project before i'm not sure if some
people are aware
but it had a little bit of a longer
production schedule
than most main titles tend to be and you
know
it's like no one likes to talk about how
long main titles take
i mean i've i've tried asking i'm like
what is normal like it's what i'm doing
completely janky and like you know we
just wouldn't fly
in other companies or you know but
people like you know it's just
it's really depends on the company and
but then um
for this one i know for a fact that it
took a long time
because for the longest time it was
mostly just me
usually uh main titles have you know a
team of people
um working on it for maybe like five
weeks um you know just cranking it out
you know making it
great you know producing you know some
of the best
main titles i've ever seen in such a
short timeline but for the longest time
i think there was a lot of red tape that
needed to kind of
be addressed including things like the
budget things like
how much money can be
allocated to buy these stock footages
what are some of the rights and um
in the middle it kind of was it
came to a little bit of a standstill but
i think during that time
um i took the time to kind of just
further ideate and i kind of try to
develop the animation
and for the longest time it was just me
working on this project
and it was near the end that i finally
got cisco and geo's help to kind of
try to you know get it all together and
try to like do all the gold plating
and so i think this project was
definitely a little bit different and i
don't think and
i'll ever work on a project like this
again because
for such a large project working on it
just by myself
i was like i'm dying i need other eyes
to look at this you know i need
i'm so limited by my own technical
skills also you know
like um where may
like even if they even if it's just
junior animators um
they could help with little things so
that i'm not
rotoing everything myself
i think it's definitely that's kind of
where having a team
is very important um one thing i do want
to talk about especially people who are
still in school
is that there's a there's this um
idea there's this notion that you can't
particular
you can't own a work unless
you've done it all start to end 100
you know and i think that's
a bad notion that discourages
collaboration
i think it's totally fine to collaborate
with people you know you get you could
if anything in every aspect it'll make
things better of course you know you got
to find the right
people got to have this the right
teamwork
going on but that's just something that
i want to tell
especially students um and
for artists in general don't be afraid
to outsource
certain things um in the past i had to
like
roto everything i had to like do little
things
but then i'm like no let's just ship it
to
let's just ship all the to work to a
company in india who'll do it like
you know for really cheap or like you
know just the studio down the road who
will
do it um and i think deli having
working like getting comfortable with
delegating
certain jobs
will help you kind of focus what needs
to be done
and probably and possibly even help you
become more comfortable as an art
director or a creative director
because a lot of creator directors or
art directors they start as
artists but as they move up to those
positions
they start becoming more the idea person
and less involved
in the direct application or the direct
creation
so it's about kind of learning to be
able to
be comfortable delegating a lot of the
work yet
also having the skills to be able to
communicate what you want and how you
want it
um so yeah sorry back to this collage
effect
well can i can i ask a question here
real quick um
so i don't think you ever answered it in
the whole
live stream but what was the timeline
for this project because i know you said
it started it had a low because you were
waiting for some answers and then
how long did it take from end to end is
that three months you know i had a hard
time
i tried to actually track that answer
recently
um one of the reasons why it's also
harder is because
i was actually working on another
project while i was working on this
project
like you know balancing things so that
um it's kind of just from looking at the
schedule it's kind of hard to see
where which project i balanced might you
know balance my time with
but i did try to kind of look at this
question answer this question
let's see let's see so the
countless safe we presented the concepts
and the design
the initial design boards with the nine
frames on february
1st i got the eight i
developed and presented the 18 frames
at march 7th
so i had a month to do that and then i
had and then spent
three and then starting from
there it was a little bit of on and off
and then
we finally presented the final render
at july
so let's say
four months maybe like which is a
ridiculous long time
for a main title but to be fair you know
a lot of it
it wasn't time spent entirely on this
and also one of the reasons why it took
so long
was because we had time you know we did
this a way ahead of time
um before the schedule was to come out
and
for a huge chunk of that time period it
was just me
so of course you know things are going
to be created a little bit
slower versus having like a whole team
on it so
you know of course we understand yeah
and by and by just me i mean animators
of course
there are there were um producers you
know work in the in the background
you know talking with client you know
making sure working behind the scenes
making sure that you know things are you
know chugging along great that you know
everything's in budget all that stuff
but yeah this part this
like i mentioned before it did kind of
have a particularly long
schedule you know due to those reasons
yeah that's good uh just because i think
uh it helps people understand uh how
much
work it takes uh regardless of the
downtime of
how something like this might um how
long it would take to
develop from from start to end and
hearing the people involved a creative
director above you
you as the main person and then two
junior uh designer animators that are
helping do
a lot of the other work it's just
helpful to see so that people in their
mind can see
if i want to do something like this what
would it take how long would it take and
then
how could i play a part in all of this
because some of the things you
identified especially with one of your
artists which i think was uh geo who was
an animator from otis
you saw their portfolio you saw their
work and you saw something in their work
that looked
related to the thing you were creating
and i think that's
one piece of the puzzle that a lot of
designers or artists don't consider when
they're putting their portfolio together
is
the thing that usually gets them in the
door is when somebody from a company
sees work that's relevant to the thing
that they're doing
so if you're a creative director and
you're hiring out
for a job you say you know what i need
this piece this piece and this piece to
solve this puzzle
so you go out into the world and the
people that are most accessible
the most the people that are most
recommended and for you that was to go
to your alma mater to go to your school
that you graduated from
those are the things where you you start
first and you say oh the square peg is
going to go into the square hole the
circle
peg is going to go into the circle hole
so uh to follow up on your advice
earlier
because people were asking how do you
get your foot in the door it's like
make the work like the studio you want
to apply it
if you want to do certain work make your
work look like that work and i think
it's as simple as that
chris joe likes to say this all the time
if there's a studio you aspire to work
at
uh look at your portfolio and look at
theirs and close the gap that's that's
all you have to do
um so you just have to be out there you
have to be known and
uh you have to be the the more
things that help point to you and
recommend you whether that's an alma
mater your network or people that you've
worked with already
these are all pluses and then if your
work just says
yeah i'm appropriate for that job i
didn't plug and play
it's it's really easy to get your foot
into the door somewhere
yeah for sure and definitely um
apply i mean just just submit your
portfolio a lot of the times when it
comes down
to you know we need freelancers we find
that
you know our book you know our
freelancer book is
highly outdated or we just you know
don't really
have any anybody and so it's important
to
just uh you know just submit yourself
get yourself known
out there work on your website um yours
you know get your work out there um for
sure you know
because you got to get noticed first um
yeah and that's how we found uh cisco
too we
looked at we looked at a list of
freelancers and decided on him because
i just uh we decided that okay like this
guy has
skills where um here's the thing
um cisco didn't have he didn't work on
this
type of stuff before he did a lot of
like ui
designs for you know like little
high-tech computer graphic looking stuff
and it you know even though he didn't
work on this collage style before i knew
that we could
use him as an artist because his work
showed that he had skills
in compositing and animating and you
know design and composition
and it so even if it's not exactly the
type of work
we look at those skill sets to
come up with a decision whether to hire
or not
yeah and i'm sure he came recommended in
the network because
he worked with a bunch of your friends
over at cantina right
with a lot of alumni that went to your
school so you guys can all just vouch
for each other it's like oh yeah cisco
that guy's
that guy's good right or so and so i was
like yeah i've worked with this guy
so recommendations go a very long way
for that and obviously at a certain
point if you're the art director
creative director
evaluating some work and you've had your
hands on the box
animating or designing stuff you know
what good work looks like versus
what mediocre look work looks like so
you could just tell
ah i can bend this person to do this
thing even though it's not showing
in their portfolio yeah and i think my
recommendations for
artists who are especially trying to do
motion graphics
is to be flexible
um as an artist you know like over time
we develop
a style like our own personal style
but if you're too limited by that style
you're not gonna get hired by anyone
unless they want that style
and if you look at my website i mean
you could see that um
not through choice you know i'm working
on the jobs that come through
the companies but i don't i try to
develop a design or a style
that the project needs you know the show
needs or the
client needs versus trying to impose
my personal style and aesthetic onto
you know the client and i think as an
artist
um definitely being a little bit more
flexible uh
having a little bit of variety just
exploring different
mediums uh aesthetics um
can you know will do a long way into
getting you noticed
because the worst thing i mean the worst
thing you could do as
uh someone who's trying to get hired is
to
literally have just pages and pages of
work that just looks all exactly the
same you know
i want to see like in it and even if
it's
within the same medium like let's say
you do 3d you know
like i want to see a frame that looks
that's 3d but maybe has something that
looks like it could be for pbs kids
but then at the same time you have
another project that looks like
you worked on iron man you know or
something like just having a little bit
of variety that shows me okay this
person
is someone who could uh
where does it handle the different types
of projects or different types of
you know whatever the project or client
needs are
yeah that's my advice
cool all right let's get back into this
i know we kind of diverged a little bit
from the
collage effect i don't know if there was
anything else to wrap up but i think
this
i mean this looks pretty clear to me in
terms of the steps since you've labeled
it
here you got your cutouts and then you
just add a little bit of paper details
on the edges so it doesn't look so
digital
and you color correct it with a little
bit of uh toning right making it warm
and then
overall you just add some nice texture
so it just feels like this was on the
photo bed scanner and then maybe it just
got all smudged up
and then all of a sudden it looks like
you scanned this in or you took a photo
of it right so
this is a way to make something that's
digital feel
more tactile and real by using real
textures and elements
and with collage composition is
definitely important
um you know the
it's important because if done
wrong it could come out comical you know
if i had
this boy's face with like a smile this
big
it turns you know it gives a different
mood a different feeling
than when it's all balanced and trying
to
show the emotion audience or what you're
trying to intend
so definitely composition is important
when trying to come up with a collage
the technical aspects of how the look
was created
is very simple for the paper and edge
effect i mean these
pictures were actually just pictures uh
what is it
that were digital pictures and you know
of course because
of you know copyrights we can't just
willy-nilly
use any picture from the internet so we
we
um you we out we used
um either usable stock footage that we
got uh through pain
or from the show that we could use for
free or
from uh free image sites like
um what is it unsplash
uh wikipedia commons some of the really
old
um was it govern government
like some of the government ones like
are free of congress
yeah library of congress so i mean yeah
i got i got
i got that question a lot you know like
oh what was you know how did you
get away how how did you you know you
use these images
and yeah they're all free images and a
lot of these images
aren't from the 60s they're just treated
to look like they are you know and
let's see and the paper edge effect is
something as simple as just
using drop shadows and roughen edge you
know
i usually i literally use one drop
shadow
that's white on one side where the light
would be coming from
to kind of get that white highlight of
the paper
and another drop and then i put a
roughen edge
roughen edge on the whole thing to kind
of give it that
little bit of organic look and then i
gave an a drop shadow
going uh black implying the shadow
the other direction to you know be the
shadow one was the highlight one was the
black shadow and that that's basically
it's it's it and then
maybe i did it a couple more times to
get to give it that
extra organicness maybe i you know i
might have added
another like look like another light
source is coming from here
or from the other way but that's it's
really as simple as that you know like
don't really have to over think
the technical aspects of certain things
i think it's
more important to kind of get the
composition
um what is it end of the framing like
just sticking to the basics you know
like
uh people like one of the things about
romero bearden's or collages if i could
go back to
some of to his uh if you go to the
deck let's see
let's see can they see my deck oh yeah
so if you look at romero bearden's work
it's
amazing and it's intricacy and its
complexity
yet it's just too much you know it's too
busy it's we don't have time
to look at every little detail if i put
a credit
a name over this frame or is it going to
stand out are people going to be able to
read it um probably not so you have to
think about
um how do you what like how can you
simplify it so that you get what you
want yet still
be able to you know incorp like be able
to do
what you needed to do and
let's say so yeah and then this is just
a page showing
some of the actual practical paper
elements
that we did uh cisco he um
[Music]
printed out and then tore some of these
as these
papers um got some close-up shots of
some of the edges helped us study how
they look like a little bit
um and for that for the boxer we
actually
used it as a transition where we started
off as
a full frame of him and started tearing
it away
little by little to rip you know and
then use that as a reveal
and the the blue and the black and blue
and the green paper
in the back is just paper that we use
kind of like
you know like a janky makeshift like
green screen that we could just easily
key out
you know and it was it's really and
technically
it was as simple as that
but it's when you get them all together
and put them in
a composition where they work in
you know in all the design elements of
you know composition
framing uh color um you know this is
kind of what you end up with and
i think it's important for artists to
not
feel that initial overwhelming of how am
i gonna
how am i gonna make something great from
the start it's about just
keeping things simple asking yourself
the questions
um what is what you know who what where
am i how like
what what is the story that you want to
tell what are the things that you need
to do and get across
and if you just add on to it little by
lit little by little
you know start with nine four nine one
start with one frame
you know you could research and
pinterest you know
like oh like where you got hundreds of
tabs on which i'm totally guilty of
but at at a certain point you just have
to start even though you might not have
a specific idea in your head and from
there it's just kind of building
on little by little until hopefully you
end up with something that you're happy
with you know
yeah yeah cool so i i think what i want
to do is i'm going to queue up our
audience thank you so much peter for
for sharing all of that i'd like to
queue up our audience for some questions
and they're asking some good questions
now but
um while we're waiting for those
questions to come in jonah could you
play the title sequence one more time
because i think we went through this
long extensive process and i know we
showed the
the title sequence right at the very
beginning and i think it'd just be
helpful for us again to revisit
all that reference all that research all
of those little techniques that you did
here and there
how it came together in the final piece
because it's nice to see
the individual storyboards and how those
fleshed out
and then now how did they get stitched
together especially with the stock
footage so
just looking at the title sequence now
there's some really cool moments where
you have all this staccato stop-motion
animation
and then you have an interesting
transition like that where it tears away
and goes back into live action and then
live action live action again
clips from the show and then you'll have
a moment where
all of a sudden it's back into the
transition of
this uh paper collage look so it's
really nice to see
how it comes together and there's
definitely magic in there and i think
for me being a motion designer myself
these were the things that attracted
me to motion design to be able to have a
mixed media approach
between traditional static design
between
film and video and then implementing all
of these other
mixed media approaches all together and
then seeing that all come together it to
me is
has always been the magic of motion
design and
it's nice to see things like this and
and and
share with our audience like what the
process is like to build something this
beautiful and this big
wow yeah for sure that's that's the
exact reason why i got into motion
design too i actually uh
went to otis myself as a concept artist
and i took
one class did one painting and i was
like oh no
this isn't for me and then like
when i took an after expects class and
made a ball bounce i was like
oh wow like this this is for me you know
like seeing things in motion
you know like get getting you know
different
being so flexible with aesthetics or
materials
yeah it's it's great you know i love
what i do
that's fantastic and i guess that was a
question
somebody was asking how did you get into
uh
title design specifically um
i mean long story short it kind of fell
on my lap just because
i worked at digital kitchen who has
that has such a big pedigree of working
on main title
sequences the before my time they made
um true the true blood dexter
six feet under um main titles so
there they are they were they were a
prestigious company
known for um main titles so that
by the time i came to digital kitchen
um was it like that was kind of the
projects that
i started getting more and more involved
in um
uh i wasn't i was there
for the narcos uh main title
but then what is it i wasn't
on the project you know i was just the
guy next to the guy
working on it but then i got so that was
my like okay so that's kind of like
you know the the pitch that's how it
works that's the steps that they got to
do
and then you know i started getting more
and more into
what is it into the projects yeah and
then
so it's definitely i was blessed
that i was able to work at a company
that had such great
uh opportunities that presented itself
to me
and you know it's just something that
you just have to have a little bit of
experience
um and grow with um not to say that you
can't be a freelancer
or a solo artist who can work on uh main
titles
but i think it's just a little bit more
easier if you work
at a company that does those types of
work
nice cool yeah yeah so um
just to echo what peter is saying if you
do
good enough work you'll get in the door
and then when you get in the door and
you do
exceptional work and you do that
repeatedly
on different things then you get you
build trust and when you build trust
inside a company
they trust you to do more like for me
working for christo at blind
i started as an intern actually his
student back in 2006
then i interned for him and then
immediately after i finished my
internship i started freelancing
for the company and then you know over a
decade later it's like then i became a
creative director and it's just it's
just this a massive
uh building trust and getting your hands
in a lot of different things where
my specialty was designed at first and
then i became a better animator and
all of a sudden i'm directing the
projects it's like these are things that
you just build up over time and
you just do a damn good job wherever
you're at
so maybe this is a another question here
somebody asked what's your favorite
title sequence
peter oh there's so many i mean
uh the first thing that comes to mind
all right the first one that comes to
mind
is american gods uh that was just
mind-blowing i mean like in terms of
just the scale
the the colors the music
i mean it was just great on all fronts
um just the concepts that it was trying
to
you know like imp like get across to
the like the the mixing of
like the religious and the history
historical aspects of the story with
like the present
and you know the technology i mean it
was great i remember being mind blown by
uh game of thrones um i'm just really
good at doing and it just keeps
i just keep getting those types of work
and i think as an artist it's definitely
uh have to what is it you gotta find
yours
find what you love doing you know um you
got and
find what you love doing um get really
good at it
if you have an interest in doing
something
like you know take the time to just
really get really good at it you know
if you love doing 3d then just take the
time to
you know just get really good at it if
you love doing
after effects or um 2d type stuff or
even you know collage animation like
stuff
just get really good at because one of
the things that i did
when i first dabbled with the idea of
doing the collage was
okay what collage type animation
is out there you know i looked i googled
i you know searched vimeo typed in
every combination of collage paper stop
motion
animation and i saw what was out there
and i
and what is it and i thought how can
i how can i do it different how can i
make it
better in a sense you know and i think
what really helped what is it sell this
concept also with the showrunner
is that it's a it's a it's a look
that isn't it's a look that is fairly
is kind of new you know i think there's
been kind of a little
there's been a trend in maine title
graphics
where it's a lot of you know very very
gorgeous and beautiful 3d
um a lot of but then
so so when the show runner came to us
with the idea that
oh i want something that will stand out
you know and i kind of looked at okay
what were the
main like the main the main titles go
like right now i saw
that a lot of them were these gorgeous
3d pieces
so i thought maybe by making it more
2d flat um collage aspect it'll kind of
stand out from the rest you know so
that was kind of just one of the the
idea
and process that kind of helped push me
towards that concept too
and the thing is i've never done this
collage uh con
animation or design before like i've
never
um and that's the thing i think when as
an
as a because i'm an artist that tries
not to impose my personal style
to a project but tries to see what the
project
needs i am always trying new things
you know i gotta look at you know what's
been done before and
uh there's this artist called blink my
brain
um blink my brain yeah i believe it's
bring back um
blink my mind bring my brain ah i'm
having a brain fart but he does
the best i mean he's got to be the best
kind of stop-motion collage paper
texture animating
guy and i was like okay like i want
something that looks like that
but in you know in my way or in what in
the way that kind of works with what i
want it to work
so i think definitely um pushing
yourself to try new things
um yeah yeah it's i don't even know what
i was talking about
originally but yeah
yeah i was gonna say uh for for collage
artists yeah there's there's definitely
been a great history of amazing people
and right now my favorite
uh contemporary collage artists and
animators are
uh alice isaac she's amazing at what she
does i think she's doing some phenomenal
work and then another person
who's been killing it for a long time is
rough mercy so if you see that guy he's
all mixed media
but amazing stuff so both of those
people i think are worth looking out for
and if
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
title design because it's its whole it's
its own
industry it's a massive industry um and
there's a few studios that do it
very very well but if you want to look
up and go down that deep well
of of studying that look up the
artofthetitle.com
and you will see the long history going
back 40 50 years of beautiful title
design
and you'll see i to me those are title
designer the most
intelligent uses of motion design
because it really takes something that's
the concept the story of
uh a movie or show and then compacting
or giving you a teaser
letting you know what it's it's going to
be
about and i think there's just so much
amazing
work that should be celebrated and part
of the title is a great place to study
that and
and find some great um great work there
um yeah just gotta find something to be
inspired by
and as as aspired towards rather than
getting
dejected and thinking oh how will i ever
get there you know
just gotta flip that you know mentality
in your head
to you know push yourself to and it's a
lot easier
to push yourself when you're feeling
inspired and
passionate um
so we're getting close to the end of the
show here um so i want to queue up our
audience for any other questions that i
saw some in there but
they were a little confusing to read
there was one specific question though
because
when we were looking at your process
obviously you did a lot of stuff in
digital
and then you did a few things practical
but when we were watching the sequence
there was a couple of moments where you
saw these white paint strokes that were
transitioning or painting scenes on and
off
were those digital or those practically
made or how were those made
uh i'm having trouble figuring out what
part they're talking about
white strips uh white white paint it was
like it looked like it was white paint
and then it was like kind of like
rolling up and down
to transition from one scene to another
white paint
i'm not sure what they're talking oh
you're talking about
i'm not sure what they're talking about
but then um but anyways it was all
those things were mostly yeah they were
all created digitally
the um some yeah just um using maths
uh cisco developed some maths
with half tones that had just the
if if i were to open up this project
it's just it would just be layers and
layers of
mattes like the mattes have mattes um
you know it's just a process that um
just included a lot of textures a lot of
overlays
um applied like a scrolling
paper crumpled paper uh texture
that's kind of like scroll like just
kind of like you know stop-motiony
stuff kind of over over everything um
little like dust
specks that you would normally get from
like film
um it's just a lot of layers of
different um design elements
it's cool all right
uh let's see
do you think canada also has a title
sequence industry
uh yes i think uh title design actually
exists all around the world in all of
like the major cities and even in
smaller cities
like for the longest time there's a
company called mk12 that
and they're still around they have done
killer killer work both in title design
and motion design but they're out
in the midwest kind of in the middle of
nowhere they're not really on
one of these big metropolitan cities yet
they're one of the most
um long-standing respected studios out
there so
it exists everywhere and because we're
all working from home too guess what
you don't have to be at a location
anymore you can be working
remotely and do some fantastic work and
i know a lot of designers
and art directors and animators who are
working remotely on these types of
things but
there are a few studios to name digital
kitchen being one of them
imaginary forces being another one uh
elastic has been doing a lot of
fantastic work for hbo and netflix
and are there any more that come to mind
for you peter that did you mention
imaginary forces
yes okay the yeah the i gotta do a
better job of looking up studios but
definitely
imagine oh yeah yeah i have a friend
uh james robertson that works there uh
harshit uh they sai
he is a creative director at um
imaginary forces he was the one that i
was talking about
that was working on narcos um so i mean
it's definitely a tight industry
um you know you start to become familiar
especially you know if you're in la
but there's no reason to think that it
has to be only l.a like
wherever there's tv and movies you know
it could be korea
like there's going to be some company
working on it you know
absolutely cool
all right um one last question here and
this is from
shamari she's asking what's your
favorite part of the process
peter oh my favorite part my favorite
part
is um it's actually kind of in the
middle
where you know what you want to do and
you're just
all you know that to move forward
is just effort you know just chugging
along putting that man hour
in um as much as i love love love
uh designing coming up with concepts and
exploring ideas
you know which is a close second there's
also a lot of like ah
no like what am i gonna do you know
that you know i could sometimes do it
out um i really i just love
uh oh yeah good question actually i i
just love
uh like once the concept has been
approved
how do you produce like how do you
manage it how does it
uh like what's the production pipeline
i actually really enjoy uh kind of
thinking about that
um like if one of the
one of the ways i did this project was
making sure that it was modular
so that each scene was its own after
effects project
so that at any point uh me or one of the
other artists can just
open up an app in after effects and
work on a scene without affecting what
someone else is doing on another scene
like if this whole project
worked on one after effects and you know
someone comes in on the server
and starts working and saving over what
you're doing that's a nightmare you know
so kind of figuring out that pipeline
making things
making sure things work organizing
um just everything you know like maybe
it's just a little bit of ocd that is a
little bit
gratifying when everything goes smoothly
you know i enjoy that
process oh you're not alone there yeah
that's one of my favorite things too
pipeline and production and problem
solving and making oh yeah problem
building the machine to make it all work
so everybody can do their job that's
also
for whatever reason i enjoy that part of
it as well
all right well i think that's a great
place to wrap up
our discussion peter if people want to
find more
of you and look up more of your work and
get in contact with you where's the best
place they could find you
uh best place they could find me is
probably
through instagram my instagram
uh hand name is just peter p4k
uh peter pack is my name and the a is in
my last name is a four
so peter p 4k um and i'll and
that's also my website peterp4k.com um i
have you know
you could i'm i'm checking though i'm
checking out instagram
uh linkedin you know could email me
that's also my email peter p gmail.com